okay let's take a question from weston
hey jason this is weston from 15 finches
we're a startup focus creative studio
and we're launching a partnership
program so think accelerator meets full
service creative
dev slash product shop we have a pretty
good pipeline
of startups right now that come through
our vc network
so the question is do you have any
advice or recommendations for how we can
get introduced or get in front of
startups that are kind of outside of
that immediate network
okay great question and the idea of
putting together a bunch of developer
and design resources
and an accelerator is one that most
people
in the community think has a weakness in
it
i'm going to explain what that weakness
is you're going to get a lot of idea
people
who want to build apps and
every single person on the planet by
definition is an ideal person because we
have these giant brains
that spew ideas all day long so what's
going to happen with your accelerator
and the real weakness of it
and the thing that you're going to have
to route around is you're going to just
get idea people who don't have the
ability to execute and then you're now
substituting your dev shop for their
ability to execute
and then when you go away you're going
to have fished for all these founders
giving them these beautiful fish and
then you leave and they starve to death
because they don't know how to fish they
don't know how to build an app
so you might inadvertently negative
signal the wrong people
to come to your accelerator which is
just generic idea people i.e the average
human
and what you really want when you're
doing an accelerator is people who are
resourceful and have the resources
to either learn to be a developer learn
to be a ux and designer
and learn those skills or somebody who's
so convincing as an idea person
using quotes an idea person just also
known as a person
you can then uh you would
much rather have the person who can who
can find those resources
and you know corral them and convince
them so
if you want to find people gosh you know
going to your vc network they're going
to give you
the rejects they're going to give you
the people who didn't have
um the ability to build apps and say oh
you can't build an app oh you're
unable to convince a developer to work
with you oh you don't have the ability
to raise a seed round
and find a developer and pay for them
okay yeah you should go
get this accelerator so i'm really
concerned about the fundamental premise
of your business
i don't think it's a good idea i think
if you're going to do this and you're
smart enough to have your own
development resources why not
just build your own ideas and do what's
called a startup studio
like beta works or science or some other
ones that have emerged
so i think you've got a flawed model
that you need to really think about
i know that wasn't the answer you're
looking for but i feel like i got to be
candid with you